hey everyone
I can't believe ADA's almost over if
you're new here veda is vlog every day
in august but I think I pretty much have
done I've done videos every day in
August that's for that's for sure
right now I'm going to Matt's to pick up
Madi oops
I'm putting you guys on some peanut
butter right now it's Friday night it's
8 p.m. and I just got a shower for the
day I'm not sure what that saying about
myself but I was editing and working old
days so that's my excuse and I'm
sticking with it Jenna that Max and so
this is her birthday today but it's
Friday night so technically tomorrow I'm
bringing her an early president Jenna
loves the dough so I thought what better
thing to get her than all three delle
albe oops sorry you guys are giving me
crap because I was giving Jenna a lame
birthday present of the purple carpet
couple rug I think it's a great gift
because she wants that rug now she's not
gonna have to buy the rug Grande I
bought it for myself originally but I
was just gonna return it but now the red
is gonna have a good home to someone who
originally wanted it and found it it's a
long story I'm done I'm done
she's going to absolutely love it holy
Christmas but I'm gonna bring some
things over to Jenna and we're gonna try
these out they're like the stick on
nails this is not sponsored I just
bought them at CVS and I'm not sure what
is gonna be the winner I think I'm gonna
go with these ones these look cool look
out it's like 8:30 at night is traffic
yeah you want some not generally was
your problem wait you got our present
yeah Jim let's see what it is the rough
yeah that's what was wrong something I
was going to purchase the rug for myself
anyway but not yet but then when Justine
said that she liked that I was like well
she realistically needs it this day so
that's okay I'll get another one but now
that you don't want the rug I can have
the rug and everyone's happy I'm sure I
wanted to see if I could guess I've got
no guesses is it a book wait I was
listening to Adele earlier on Alexa lie
about what I said and then and then she
played Shawn Mendes thanks Josh
you're where did you get these did you
go to the office no actually I got that
money in some time now
only because so I like to make really
fun birthday invites for people so my
plan was I was gonna like take a really
cool artsy shot of all of the CDs and
then Photoshop John his face overtop of
Adele's face but like there's no real
way to photoshop a separate half of her
face cuz it's basically her face we've
no idea what is in here Susie sent us
some little surprises from Hawaii
oh man my face just no way a boruto not
oh my god is like a narc okay I don't
know what the hell I need to do but we
need to get Suzy she always gets such
cute and thoughtful little gift so as
you guys have seen if you're on my
gaming channel you know that me and Matt
have been playing one view ones and he
literally just destroys me so we he had
this great idea to play me and Jenna but
Jenna's actually pretty good at call of
duty and when you're playing a to be
wanted hardpoint that's pretty hard to
win to be honest
oh my god I'm sorry is there we playing
like like Koch ham rolls or something I
don't know I don't even know what those
are why would I know well I don't know I
don't even know what you're like are you
speaking I think like I'm just making
stuff up like words you're coming on a
really good job though surprisingly like
right listen I need to address this in a
video because I thought if you're a call
duty fan you understand the level of
advantage you have when you have one
extra person at hard point so I posted
this video now everybody thinks I suck
and and I was about to post a snapchat
earlier Jenna and I collectively decided
like this is not a good idea I want to
say this in the most like uncock e way
like noncom it's pretty hard for you to
it
to be honest yeah and they don't
understand the level of like you guys
aren't bad like you guys play call of
duty you guys a play destiny like you
guys have been gaming as long as me
obviously you don't play it every day
but let me say this I am still very good
at call of duty and I without sounding
like a jerk 99.99% of you could catch
these hanging
and call do you like there are not many
people that can be I just want that to
be known what does catch these hands I
mean I'm gonna put hands on you you know
I'm saying like I know I mean I was
excited when you're like calsters do not
want twisting not to cut you off I think
you're you're really good that'll world
champion like a four or five times
mlgchina I don't know what I got to do
to make people think I'm gonna call Dede
you guys did beat me though fair and
square good you guys did a fantastic job
of like throwing nades and tacticals and
like playing smart I I would be out I
was beside myself
I even had a guardian ready because I
was like set you guys were pushing
around chokepoints like coming in from
different angles I was like dude what
the hell I thought that was gonna be
walking apart I'll play again yes this
time me too I'm gonna I'm gonna have
guardians I forgot that you have to make
your own classes they don't yeah it was
pretty fun I'm but I had a great time so
if you guys want to check it out go
watch it on my gaming channel I'm also
trying to yell less because even when
I'm editing I'm so annoying and I'm so
sorry but that's what I am like when I
play video games go home now I forgot
what else I brought us I brought us
something fun to do today I brought us
stick on Manny's pool we can still do
that right now
do you want to do them now no we could
do them tomorrow you just stick them on
I got these ones these out in my car to
see if my new car has this type of oh no
do you see this look at this there's no
audio
pretty much the worst thing ever that
can happen to youtuber anyone who's
filming anything is when you film
something and the audio doesn't
microphone must have come and plugged
last night when I was transferring my
camera from the car to my house anyway
what I did was a little unboxing i
unboxed one of these new movies it's
like a rose gold and it's got the
built-in lightning cables so here's me
opening it
I also opened this other one which is
not upstairs and I'm not gonna walk
downstairs to get it a little bit too
late and with that I will see you guys
later
make sure you guys wish my sister happy
birthday at Jenny's Eric on Twitter and
it's me Jenna e you're on YouTube